MaMartine Biron, Michel David et
StStéphanie Grandmont.
BoBonsoir à tous les trois.
- - (tous): Bonsoir.
- - On ne peut pas ne pas parler
dede ce verdict pour la belle-me
dede la petite-fille de Granby,
cocoupable sur toute la ligne. e
lele disais dans de jeu, cela a
chchoqué, ça a secoué le Québec.
IlIl y a eu cette commission, on
veverra ce que ça donne, on l'au
ququ'il il y a un projet de loi
dédéposée, pour moderniser la D.
IlIl y a ce procès de la belle-
mmère. Le procureur global
enentendre en quelques secondesl
a a dit : c'est la seule façon e
rerendre un peu de dignité à cee
jejeune fille, que cette mort
seserve à quelque chose. Martin?
- - Je pense qu'on écoutait
l'l'extrait. Désolé. C'est sur e
lele décès de cette petite filla
bobousculé beaucoup le
gogouvernement de François
LeLegault. Dès le début du mand,
lele gouvernement de François
LeLegault voulait mettre en plae
unune commission parlementaire
popour réformer la DPJ. Donc qud
cecette petite fille est décédé,
cecela a bousculé les choses ete
gogouvernement s'est vraiment ms
àà la tâche et on peut dire
ququ'ils ont assez bien réussi
leleur coup parce que Régine
LaLaurent a quand même dirigé
cecette commission d'enquête avc
unune main de fer et le ministre
LiLionel Carmant, quand même lon
dedes feux de la rampe, à monter
cece projet de loi. Ce projet "
inintérêt de l'enfant au coeur e
lala protection de la jeunesseÇa
a a l'air de rien, il y a eu
plplusieurs critiques beaucoup e
gegens dise : mais l'intérêt de
l'l'enfant est déjà considéré.
MaMais la loi va changer, si bin
quque l'intérêt de l'enfant, c't
pepeut-être qu'il ne soit plus
avavec ses parents biologiques n
totout cas dans le cas de cette
pepetite, si elle n'avait pas éé
avavec sa mère biologique et pe-
êêtre que les choses auraient éé
didifférentes. La loi ne
pepermettait pas ce genre de
dédécision alors on s'en va là.t
jeje peux vous dire que Monsieur
LeLegault est très satisfait dee
prprojet de loi. A été déposé à
l'l'Assemblée nationale
d'd'ailleurs, Québec solidaire
s's'est levé, Parti québécois
élélever et il y a seulement des
lilibéraux qui n'ont rien dit.
C'C'est une réforme majeure quia
étété proposée avec la réforme e
lala DPJ. Opaque et qui émane, e
lele rappelle, parce qu'on n'a s
dédécouvert cette journée-là gre
auau drame qu'il y avait des
chchoses à réformer à la DPJ, ms
lala mort de cette jeune fille a
étété un catalyseur pour faire
acaccélérer les réformes que l'n
vovoulait faire.
- - Tout à fait et vous savez, a
CACAQ avant qu'elle prenne pouvr
etet même dans les premiers mois
dede gouvernement Legault, un ds
rereproches qu'on leur faisait,
c'c'était de manquer d'empathie.
MaManquer d'empathie envers un u
totout le monde finalement. Dans
lele cas de ce drame et face aux
jejeunes de façon générale, je
pepense que le gouvernement a bn
réréagi. La réaction a été rapi,
MaMadame Laurans a fait un bon
trtravail et le gouvernement a
vrvraiment donné l'impression
ququ'il voulait faire quelque
chchose. Au total, je pense que
popolitiquement, c'est réussi
cocomme test, disons, pour le
gogouvernement Legault, et poura
sosociété en général, on verra
jujusqu'à quel point ces mesures
vovont être efficaces. Je trouve
totoujours un peu fatiguant de
vovoir que sauf erreur, le rectr
nanational de la santé publiquea
dedemeurer un sous-ministre, un
pepeu comme M. Arruda. Mais de
fafaçon générale, la réaction
ététait bonne.
- - Stéphanie?
- - Effectivement, je pense qu'n
s's'entend pour dire que la
cocommission de Régine Laurent,e
prprojet de loi, tout cela
sasatisfait les attentes et les
acacteurs en présence. Et cette
anannée parce que dans le passél
y y avait probablement une dizae
dede commissions et de comités
d'd'experts qui avaient été
mamandatés pour s'occuper de cee
réréforme de la DPJ et puis je
didirais parier mais il n'y avat
papas grand-chose qui avait boué
fafaute de fonds et faute de
susuivi. Et cela avait fait en
sosorte que quand même, le nombe
d'd'enfants à la DPJ avait doubé
enen 25 ans. Donc ce n'était pas
glglorieux. On espère que là ona
vrvraiment mararqué un point
totournant. Donc que oui, de
bebelles avancées mais il y a
enencore énormément de chemin à
fafaire parce qu'on le sait, à a
DPDPJ, il manque de bras, il
mamanque des intervenants pour
rerevaloriser cette profession i
onon veut que ce ne soit pas des
poportes tournantes et qu'on est
dedes intervenants qui soient
asassez nombreux, qui ne soit ps
épépuisé, pour prendre en charg.
PaParce que ce n'est pas facile,
cece travail. Et donc, on veut
ququ'ils puissent faire comme il
fafaut. Ce n'est pas vrai que tt
lele monde doit aller à la DPJÇa
dedevrait être des soins
inintensifs, si on veut, pas la
prpremière ligne. Donc il faut
ininvestir aussi en première lie
popour désengorger la DPJ.
- - Et sur le plan judiciaire, e
lele disais, il n'y a personne i
sosort aujourd'hui du palais de
jujustice Trois-Rivières en dist
: : c'est une grosse victoire
brbravo. C'est d'une tristesse
ininfinie des deux côtés et le
prprocureur, Monsieur Bussière,l
a a peut-être le mieux résumé, e
lele disais plus tôt, la journé.
CeCette culpabilité de meurtre u
dedeuxième degré, c'est un signl
quque l'on envoie à cette jeune
fifille. On l'écoute.
- - Écoutez, c'est beaucoup
d'd'émotion et si ce verdict-là
rerend un peu de dignité à cette
jejeune fille, c'est déjà énorm.
- - Martine, cela résume bien,
c'c'est que personne que les
prprocureurs étaient émus et on
l'l'a vu, c'était dur. On a déct
leles horreurs tout au long de e
prprocès. Notre journaliste
AmAmélie, jour après jour, elle
enentendait des choses dures. Et
llà, ils ont réussi quand même e
fafaçon exemplaire à ce que
jujustice soit faite selon la
prpreuve.
- - Le système, il y a des fails
dadans le système et il va failr
enencore, c'est un peu notre
AuAurore, Aurore Gagnon des tems
momoderne. C'était quand même un
191920 et 100 ans plus tard, ona
enencore un cas très grave.
EtEt c'est ça, c'est d'essayer e
momoins possible que le système
sosoit faillible, qu'on soit
cacapable de relever le défi. Je
trtrouvais cela intéressant ce e
didisait Stéphanie, c'est que
c'c'est une grosse machine, la
DPDPJ, c'est une une grosse
mamachine, c'est beaucoup de ges
ququi entourent les enfants et
cecela demande de s'arrimer avec
lala police, avec les écoles, ac
leles familles. Et c'est un gros
dédéfi. C'est bien beau d'avoirn
cacadre et un bon projet de loi,
mamais de mettre tous les morcex
dede casse-tête ensemble, ça va
êêtre tout un défi. Opaque et
c'c'est une tâche énorme, il fat
lele dire, pour n'importe quel
ététat que de pallier aussi les
drdrames familiaux, les capacits
paparentales, des responsabilits
paparentales. Ce n'est pas de tt
rerepos. Stéphanie, vous avez
raraison de le souligner, il
mamanque de bras et ceux qui sot
llà sont débordés.
- - C'est vrai dans tout le
sysystème de santé mais je
vovoudrais que c'est vrai de fan
gégénérale, on a vu les
édéducatrices, les hôpitaux, la
DPDPJ. Dans ce cas, ce que j'ai
trtrouvé quand même fascinant au
cocours de tout ce processus,
c'c'est que cet événement a
dédéclenché une espèce de
sesentiment de culpabilité
cocollective. Tout le monde, on
s's'est dit : mais comment ça se
fafait que ça peut arriver au
QuQuébec en 2020, en fait en 209
ququand c'est arrivé. Il y a un
sesentiment que ça n'a pas de bn
sesens et je pense que ce
sesentiment est suffisamment fot
popour que, en tout cas dans
l'l'avenir immédiat, il y a des
prpressions pour qu'il y ait des
rérésultats et qu'il du personnl
s's'ajoute. Évidemment ça dépend
auaussi des conditions que le
gogouvernement est capable de
fafaire pour rendre ce travail
atattirant. Il est clair qu'il a
dedes gens qui ont la vocation
mamais il y a des limites à
trtravailler dans des conditions
imimpossibles. Alors disons quee
susuis relativement confiant mas
ilil va falloir que la pression
cocollective demeure.
- - Oui, il ne faut pas attendre
d'd'autres drames. Je vais chanr
lele plan de me pardonner et vos
alallez me suivre, vous êtes des
prprofessionnels. La CAQ, la
ststratégie de Monsieur Legaulte
s's'en prendre à Gabriel Nadeau-
DuDubois, je vais garder cela pr
dedemain, pour mon panel demain.
JeJe vais aller tout de suite àa
CACAQ et le PLQ, c'était la fine
sesession, avec Madame Dominique
AnAnglade et Monsieur Legault. e
prprends la balle au bond parce
quque Michel, vous dîtes : le
drdrame de la fillette, on ne vt
papas que ça se reproduise. Et e
quque l'on veut pas que ça ne se
rereproduise, c'est ce qui s'est
papassé dans les CHSLD. Cela
dédépasse la joute partisane,
c'c'est comme une prise de
coconscience. Est-ce que dans la
jojoute politique, combien de
tetemps ça va se répéter? On
écécoute l'échange de Mme Anglae
avavec Monsieur Legault hier.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
PaParti libéral du Québec
- - Est-ce que le premier
miministre, qui était le chef
dede la cellule de crise, était
lele seul à ne pas être au court
ququ'on allait à l'abattoir
dadans nos CHSLD?
- - Tout le monde cherchait
dede l'équipement. Donc Monsieur
lele président, dès qu'on a eu
dede l'information, on a agi.
- - Le preremier ministre ne réd
papas à la question. Je demande
auau premier ministre de s'élev.
- - C'est juste quand même assez
spspécial d'entendre la cheffe
dede l'opposition officielle,
apaprès la semaine qu'elle vient
dede connaître, de demander
dede s'élever.
- - Monsieur le groupe de
réréférences au mot abattoir Mme
AnAnglade nous dit sur ensemble
susur ce débat sur les CHSLD à
l'l'Assemblée nationale? Les
papartis d'opposition veulent se
dédémarquer là-dessus. Ça fait s
sesemaines qu'il frappe sur ce
clclou.
C'C'est à peu près 25 questions
ququi portent la situation dans
leles CHSLD. C'est sûr que notre
cocollègue Thomas Gerbet a donné
dedes munitions en révélant les
cocourriels qui démontrent que e
gogouvernement avait été inform,
quque les CHSLD étaient
vuvulnérables. Alors l'oppositin
frfrappe sur le clou jour après
jojour, ils veulent garder
l'l'histoire vivante et on va
asassez loin. Mme Anglade a
bebeaucoup monté, hélas beaucoup
dede gros mots. Remarquez que
MoMonsieur Legault est assez bon
dadans ce jeu aussi. Et on veut
popousser Monsieur Legault dans
unune situation où on aura cette
enenquête publique. C'est la fin
dede la session et on veut marqr
leles esprits pour qu'au tour de
lala dinde dans les vacances de
NoNoël, que l'on parle de la
gegestion des CHSLD pendant la
prpremière vague par le
gogouvernement Legault.
- - Est-ce que c'est un présagee
cece qui va continuer à arriver
apaprès où on va donner le tout
popour le tout maintenant et on
esest conscient qu'il a peut-ête
unune fin à cela?
- - Je pense que ça va continue.
AuAu printemps, Le coroner va
rereprendre ses audiences. On
veverra ce qui va en sortir. Ele
vava remettre un rapport et on
pepeut déjà penser que le rappot
nene sera pas très positif poure
gogouvernement. On va brasser le
totout et comme c'est à peu près
lala seule faille que le
gogouvernement, qui est apparu
didisons au cours du mandat,
fifinalement, c'est la première
fofois que le gouvernement est
coconstamment sur la défensive.
MaMais quand on a dit cela, on
reregarde que de façon générale,
leles gens sont tous d'accord pr
didire que c'est épouvantable ce
ququi est arrivé dans les CHSLD,
mamais quand on regarde
l'l'appréciation générale de la
gegestion de la pandémie, on vot
quque le gouvernement conserve
enencore un taux de satisfactio!
MaMaman élevée et les gens, tout
enen se désolant, je pense qu'is
apapprécient l'action du
gogouvernement en fonction de ce
quque cela a représenté pour eu.
PoPour les gens, les parents, ls
vivictimes dans les CHSLD le set
épépouvantables. Mais de façon
gégénérale, les gens ont le
sesentiment que somme toute, ça
auaurait pu être bien pire et
coconsentir pas si mal.
EtEt malgré les efforts répétés,
ququi vont continuer pendant la
cacampagne, ça ne va pas ébranlr
lele gouvernement et je doute
bebeaucoup qu'ils finissent pare
rérésigner à commander une enque
pupublique. Ce n'est pas la même
chchose qu'au moment où
j'j'enchaînais été pris avec la
cocorruption dans l'industrie de
lala construction. Monsieur
ChCharvet était très impopulairà
cece moment, il en était à son
trtroisième mandat, ce n'est
vrvraiment pas la situation dans
lalaquelle se retrouve Monsieur
LeLegault aujourd'hui.
- - Vous définira pas de
cocommission d'enquête. Stéphan,
susur cette répétition de
l'l'attaque sur les CHSLD, croy-
vovous aussi que cela va
cocontinuer? On n'a pas fini?
- - J'ai l'impression que oui ms
enen même temps je pense, je sus
bibien d'accord avec ce que Micl
didit, c'est que la CAQ a une
ararmure incroyable, c'est comme
sisi personne ne réussit à la
pepercée. Mais dans les derniers
sosondages dans l'opinion, on vt
quque la gestion des CHSLD, c'et
unune faille qui se dessine, tot
cocomme l'accès aux médecins età
lala première ligne. Donc il y a
lele Parti libéral qui évidemmet
esessaie de rentrer par cette
fafaille mais en mettant, commel
tatape tout le temps sur le même
clclou, il y a peut-être une
cecertaine lassitude et avec Mme
AnAnglade, il y a une surenchère
dadans son vocabulaire qui n'est
pepeut-être pas judicieuse.
JeJe pense que la CAQ ne fera ps
dede commission d'enquêête mêmei
çaça serait peut-être souhaitab.
C'C'est vrai qu'on a déjà
plplusieurs enquêtes qui font la
prpreuve que le travail se fait.
OnOn obtient de l'information,
dodonc d'un côté on se dit : à
ququoi bon avoir une commission
enencore par-dessus qui
momobiliserait tout l'appareil
gogouvernemental pendant des mo?
- - Il faudrait songer là-dessu.
AvAvez-vous vu des sondages là-
dedessus? Je vous pose la questn
nanaïvement. Il me semble que jn
aiai pas vu. Voulez-vous que le
gogouvernement Legault lance une
auautre commission d'enquête
pupublique sur ce qui s'est pasé
dadans les CHSLD? On n'a pas vu
cecela? Ils ont dû sonder le
gogouvernement par contre.
- - Eux, ils ont sondé mais les
cacalendriers les favorisent pae
ququ'on est à moins d'un an des
élélections, le rapport du
cocoroner, celui de la commissae
àà la santé. Ils vont avoir tenr
lele coup jusqu'à ce que ces
rarapports sont déposés et aprè,
ilils vont être presque rendus à
l'l'élection. Peut-être que ce
sesera un enjeu de campagne
élélectorale.
- - Est le danger peut-être come
lele dit Stéphanie pour
l'l'opposition de ne parler quee
cecela, mais on verra. Il y a
auaussi un phénomène de fin de
sesession, la bouilloire, la
tetempérature qui monte dans les
tetermes utilisés. Demain, on va
fafaire le bilan des autres
paparties et de cette nouvelle
ststratégie de Monsieur Legaulte
s's'en prendre à Gabriel Nadea